all right we are live for something that
I haven't done for quite a while namely
uh philosophy pop-ups which are kind of
impromptu chants that I have with my
viewers and subscribers usually I give
patreon uh members the supporters of the
work that I do a little bit of lead time
but today I decided to do this kind of
out of the blue
so while we're waiting for uh people to
pop in I'll give you a really brief
rundown on what I'm doing in this one so
I taught for Marquette University last
semester three sections of classes one
was a class that I'd taught several
times before which they call foundations
of philosophy and is really just sort of
a glorified introduction to philosophy
course with a couple extra bells and
whistles mandated by committees you
could say the other was a new upper
level core class mainly for seniors it's
a required class and it's called service
of faith and promotion of Justice which
you know sounds like a kind of preachy
class but you know kind of also fits the
bill for a university that is at these
still nominally Catholic and Jesuit
which Marquette University is and we
could have a whole other conversation
about marquette's identity and what's
happened in Catholic Education because
if you look at the decision making that
happens at Marquette it's not only not
directed by any sort of uh real
religious values but actually in
contradiction to them much of the time
and it's been that way for a long time
anyway so this is this is a class that's
supposed to be like a Capstone and you
know make students think about some big
big topic some big issue
and different people you know set
different uh problems that they work
with so some people like focus on debt
or homelessness or you know I actually
considered focusing on food insecurity
I've seen some of my colleagues do
things like faith and reason where it's
not really a social issue so much and
much more a a metaphysical or
epistemological issue and I was talking
with my wife about the idea of doing
food stuff and then suddenly I realized
well how I do all this work on anger and
philosophy both in sort of a theoretical
and also practical way it's a huge
problem in our society it's gotten worse
you could say in the last couple decades
and philosophy as it turns out has a lot
to contribute to to adequately
understanding this this difficult
emotion going Way Way Back Into ancient
philosophy in the west and so why don't
I make that my topic and so that's what
I did last semester with two sections of
that class I drew on resources that I
already had I you know developed new
resources you may have seen some of the
videos and podcasts on you know people
like say Plutarch or uh John
um uh Chris's or you know some some
other well Aristotle Thomas Aquinas
um Seneca so I I uh I thought it was
kind of a cool thing to do and then uh
as is typically the case is if you're an
adjunct at Marquette they leave you kind
of high and dry and don't even say
goodbye your semester is over and and
that's it and so I thought okay
that's fine I'll just you know work on
my other stuff because I'm a busy guy
and I'll keep teaching at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design rather than
at Marquette just down the road over
there
um well anyway
last Tuesday the assistant chair of the
department emailed me and he said hey is
there any way that you can take on a
section on Tuesdays and Thursdays of
this upper level core class
so that's a week before classes start
and I thought about it and I was like
well do I want to do this again you know
um gotta show up there and I got all
this other stuff to do but it's also
like guaranteed money and I do like
teaching students face to face and you
know I've already taught the class so I
could take what I've got and you know
improve it a little bit and it wouldn't
be like starting a whole new class from
the ground up like I did last semester
so I said yeah okay I'll do that
and uh long story short I'm in the
system now and I'm going to be teaching
the class so
I thought
um you know I would uh do a little talk
about that what we're going to cover in
the class the whole point of the class
and that sort of business and then you
could ask whatever questions you want to
I know people are interested in the
classes that I teach people have been
asking about the reading list so maybe
that's the place to start I've uh I've
got a textbook for the class which uh I
don't have the cover on because I don't
like book covers but you can see it
right here Martha nussbaum's anger and
forgiveness although I'm seeing it kind
of reversed in this and it's it's not a
it's not a bad book it's actually I
would say decent to good it's not great
I'm actually going to do a review of
this book and some of its weaknesses and
you know
idiosyncrasies but it works for the
students it's you know quite readable
um Nussbaum uses plenty of examples
invokes a lot of the people that are you
know important to read when it comes to
anger at least in in Western philosophy
and she's thinking about the larger
social context that we're in so it is a
matter of anger and Justice it's
actually subtitled resentment generosity
Justice and those are things that she
comes back to over and over again so
we're using this book and then what else
are we reading so I'm gonna run through
them fairly quickly
um we are oh this is the wrong one let
me pull up the the one for this semester
here we go
um we're starting off with Audrey Lord's
piece the uses of anger which is uh
quite good and um well worth reading and
it kind of situates the the discussion
you know Lord thinks that anger
is important to use to harness
um and Nussbaum is going to take a
position that's a bit more suspicious of
anger in working for justice in trying
to change things for the better then
we're reading uh some some of ashless
the humanities
um looking at that because Nussbaum
brings it up and then we jump right into
Aristotle and we look at rhetoric book
ones discussion of anger which is very
very important Aristotle is one of the
first people to really analyze how anger
Works what it is what causes it he
doesn't you know necessarily Define
everything perfectly but he really does
a lot of important work that sets the
agenda then we're meeting somebody Who
You're probably less familiar with I
mean everybody's heard of Aristotle
there's this guy Joseph Butler and he's
you know he's kind of an important
really modern uh Theologian and
philosopher
um and we're reading two of his sermons
that have to do specifically with anger
and forgiveness and I really like his uh
discussions they're they're great for
setting the agenda then we're going to
read some Martin Luther King we're going
to read this uh piece unfulfilled hopes
um then we jump into lactances
lactancius was a very important early
Church Father a Latin writer and he's
got A Treatise called on the anger of
God
where he says God does in fact get angry
at us not quite in the same way that we
do but he has to feel anger uh because
it's connected to God's goodness and he
takes on the stoics and the epicureans
and to a lesser extent the other
philosophical schools of his his time
then we're going to read Aristotle's
Nick and McCain ethics book four
discussion of anger and virtues and
vices
um then we look at John chrysostom he
has uh two homilies that are
particularly important one on uh Paul's
letter to the Ephesians one on the
gospel of Matthew we're going to look at
Augustine of Hippo after that some
sermons some letters some discussions of
anger
um we'll also be looking at some some
texts from you know the gospels and
Paul's letters and from uh earlier
Hebrew writings for particularly the
wisdom literature and some of the
narratives talking about that then we'll
be reading the entirety of seneca's book
on anger which is a classic in
discussions of anger so we're reading
through the whole thing Nussbaum kind of
agrees with Seneca on some things kind
of disagrees so it's a nice counter
position
um
we'll be reading euripides Medea talking
about her one of the classic figures of
anger in the ancient world then we're
going to look at the stoic philosopher
Epictetus and what he says about Medea
and other things having to do with anger
and the discourses uh we'll be looking
at Thomas aquinas's discussions of anger
and the sumatia logiai looking at some
some uh bits of Marcus aurelius's
meditations where he talks about anger
looking at Adam Smith's the theory of
moral sentiments where he discusses
anger you may only associate Smith with
you know The Wealth of Nations but he
wrote another big book that's just as
important called the theory of moral
sentiments and then we're going to
backtrack a bit and read some some Plato
looking at the euthyphro and the
gorgeous and the discussions of anger
there we'll look at some Jeremy Bentham
the great utilitarian philosopher and
his principles of morals and legislation
and then we finish up by reading
plutarch's little work on controlling
anger and we finished the semester by
looking at John cassian's institute's
book eight and Gregory's moralia and job
where they're talking about anger or
wrath as one of the seven deadly sins or
the eight capital devices so a good bit
of reading and every week during the
class they generally except when we're
just reading Seneca or just reading
Plutarch they're reading a little bit of
the Nussbaum book you know maybe 10
pages or so five to ten pages and then
they're reading one of these other
selections and in my classes we do a lot
of discussion I do some lecturing but my
lecture style is to you know ask
questions ask them to provide examples
take ideas and put them up on the board
and then you know examine them back and
forth so my my lecture style is you know
trying to engage the the students and I
might incorporate some exercises for
class this time around well we'll see
what happens you know
um I'm throwing this together at the
last minute I hadn't been planning on
actually doing this and I've got well
three days before I got a walk in front
of these students with a pretty much
fully baked course in mind I am going to
be adding some some resources that
you'll see you know I'm there's videos
that I need to shoot on some of these
thinkers and podcast episodes that go
along with them I provide them with
lesson pages when I can or also with
um handouts that I develop for my
classes
um and uh you know every week they have
work to do but it's not a particularly
tough class that way they have a quiz
that I let them take as many times as
they want
I'm mainly interested it's a sort of low
level stuff I'm mainly interested in
seeing them you know get it stuck in
their head and get it right and then
there's a discussion forum that they
engage in each week that's a little bit
more substantive work on their part and
they have to engage each other so we've
got that nice way of connecting up with
their classmates outside of class and
and you know working through the text
and then the other things that they do
the two main projects for the class one
is at the beginning they they do kind of
a self-assessment of where they are in
terms of anger and they kind of keep
track of that along the way and then at
the end of the semester they do another
self-assessment and you know think about
what progress they've made personally in
terms of anger who was useful for them
uh what practices or ideas they managed
to successfully apply and then the other
thing is sort of an integrative project
that is connected with their their major
you know and
um you know the majors for this class at
Marquette could be everything from
Supply Chain management to theater to
you know education to nursing to you you
pick it and there's guaranteed to be
somebody in my class that's that's from
that
um so you know it's very rare too that I
get a philosophy student I did have one
philosophy student in my class last
semester but usually it's it's people
from other disciplines and I like that
you know because that shows you that
philosophy is valuable the fact that you
can apply it as a non-expert in other
fields right so
it's easy to teach philosophy students
let alone philosophy graduate students
it's much tougher to teach a philosophy
class to non-majors especially
non-majors who are like why the hell do
I have to take this damn core class
right so I try to make it as interesting
for my students as possible you know a
lot of them write me after the semester
is over and they're like oh I got a lot
out of this you know I'm happy with this
um
I can take some of these things and
apply them in real life and so I think
that that's really quite quite good so
that is what I'm doing for this class
I've given you the readings I've given
you the you know sort of General
approach that I take
um you know the the means of assessment
as we call them in the education
industry meaning the types of activities
and assignments that they get graded on
so now
um you know I'll just take questions on
on this and related topics and uh you
know if we don't use up the whole hour
that I carved out that's A-Okay I got
class work to do and other things to do
but if you do have questions or comments
I'm happy to you know answer them or
respond to them so Marco actually says I
wish I could take this class it sounds
very interesting
so I
I'm not going to take this class as such
and simply put it into
um you know a not for credit personal
enrichment class
um in part because
you know when we're doing online classes
that are not in a college setting we
have a lot more flexibility with this
class I get you know essentially at with
with breaks and stuff 14 weeks to work
with and everything has to be crammed
into that so I think I probably will
develop some
smaller classes
that have to do with philosophers and
theologians discussing anger in my study
with Sadler teachable Academy that I
have where you know I've got my
Aristotle class and
philosophical worldviews and values and
the Epictetus class and I'll be bringing
out some other additional classes so I
think I'll I'll probably
um do that in in the future
um but it won't be for credit it'll be
it'll be you know for other things but
it'll provide people with an opportunity
and you know this is uh along different
lines I've actually been thinking so
years and years ago some of you may have
seen these videos
um I did a lecture series lecture and
discussion uh for the Kingston Public
Library called understanding anger
and I did I was supposed to do a whole
year but then we moved back here to
Milwaukee right so we left New York we
came here and I finished up with uh the
9th or 10th lecture I want to say the
nine the 10th because we did leave in
October and uh so I didn't get through
through the whole sequence and I never
really you know with a year you can't
cover everything you'd like to cover but
I've been thinking about
[Music]
um
resuscitating that that series as
something that I do like this you know
with uh me giving kind of a presentation
and
um
people asking questions and putting some
readings up there ahead of time
and just like you know it wouldn't just
be over the course of a year maybe it'd
be over the course of a couple years and
we could zero in on some thinkers at
greater length you know like we wouldn't
cram all the stoics into one single
session
um
you know or or we could come back to
Aristotle or we could we could do a lot
more literature as well which I think is
quite important and interesting
so there's you know there's some
possibilities Jacob says would love to
attend this class or really any classes
yeah I mean it's it's going to be
um there goes the dryer it's going to be
a decent class
um
I mean this is one of the things that
that kind of sucks right you'd have to
be enrolled in Marquette and be here in
Milwaukee and show up twice a week to it
um it's uh there's a lot of things that
that get in the way of that and you
might actually like some of the other
classes that I'm teaching like I'm
teaching a philosophy as a way of life
class for Milwaukee Institute of Art
design that one's online and
asynchronous but again you'd have to be
like enrolled as a my ed student but I'm
looking to how I can
you know do some of these things not the
entire class necessarily but at least
some of these things for Learners all
over the world who who do want to
participate in in this sort of stuff so
you know you want to like check
um social media and uh
I'm gonna be starting you know years ago
we started a mailing list that I haven't
been using uh email list uh and I'll
start doing that some updates on that as
well
so all right uh Jason says which topic
in philosophy do you think is most
interesting I don't have you know a lot
of times when people ask me like most
best favorite I don't really have
answers to that I'm kind of um
spread out over a number of things I
mean the topic of anger obviously I'm
very interested in been studying it and
contributing to philosophical
understanding of it for over two decades
um there's all sorts of like little
projects that I've had here and there
that I call philosophical detective work
where I'm reading somebody I'm like this
is a really interesting topic
um the issue of the will and how we
shape our character that's really
Central to me and I do collaborative
work with uh my friend Harold cavly on
that I mean obviously uh philosophy and
heavy metal you know and I've got a
collaborator for that actually more than
one Ken Blackwell has has been to uh our
classic metal classes and made some
really significant contributions of his
own to that when Scott truly and I do
that so I don't really have a favorite
Topic in philosophy I you know that's
kind of a detriment right because I I'm
not hyper specialized uh which means
that I'm always kind of playing catch-up
right
um
so Ken says I've not read the suggested
course book but reading the synopsis it
sounds quite interesting definitely see
parallels with some stoic ideas of anger
yeah so I should say a little bit about
Nussbaum so why why do do I go with this
is it just because she's a big famous
name actually that's one of the things I
kind of dislike about Nussbaum she's one
of those people who is sort of like
Norman mailer Norman mailer said that he
had an imperialistic ambition to like
you know dominate every genre of
literature and no spam was kind of like
that there's not an area that Nussbaum
won't try to to move into right uh and
and talk something about and she's
generally pretty good but she's not
outstanding I would say compared to some
of the other great authors of our time
like say Juliana's or Nancy Sherman or
Aleister McIntyre who are covering
similar similar areas you know
um but it's a good book because she is
framing things in terms of
you know these parenting well what is
anger how does it work
um should we rely upon it or not she
comes up with her own New Concept that
she calls the transition or transition
anger which is worth exploring I'll
probably do some videos about that
over the course of the semester
um and you know she does steer it in
interesting ways she's a little bit too
focused on law I would say
when it comes to thinking about social
matters
um
but that's because she's she's also a
lot Professor so
you know that's
there aren't any perfect books
all right
um BG I attend a secret underground
class in the basement of a bar regarding
anger but the rules dictate I'm not
allowed to talk about it well you
already broke the rule right there right
um
so probably a reference to Fight Club
there
uh German Cortez what reasons does this
bomb have to be skeptical about the
usefulness of anger in relation to
Justice do you agree with them I'm I'm
so let's position it like this you've
got all these thinkers that take anger
seriously as a moral and political
um
phenomenon
and they range the gamut from the stoics
some Christian authors who are like zero
let's call it Zero Tolerance anger is
never good so seneca's in there uh John
Cassian is in there right and then
you've got like Aristotle and Aristotle
gets presented by Seneca as if like he's
like Pro anger and Aristotle's not he
does think that you you do need there is
such a thing as virtuous anger but watch
out because what you think is virtuous
anger in yourself probably isn't right
so there's there if we have a spectrum
here most of the readers that we're
reading with the the other end of the
spectrum being it like get angry all the
time it's good for you you know don't
let anyone push you around they're all
from like this middle position on uh
you know to to the to the Other Extreme
and Nussbaum would be kind of in here
she she's
you know she doesn't want to go as far
as the stoics she's also very suspicious
of any uh religious
orientation towards this so she's kind
of a nice foil in this respect and she
tends to think that
um
anger
anger can be useful
for getting things started for directing
our attention but then we need to
transition it into something that's
either a different kind of anger or not
anger at all
um and this is what she calls the
transition and I
I you know I'm
a little skeptical of that so I'm
probably in that Continuum I'm I'm
closer to Aristotle and some of the
other Christian authors like Augustine
and John chrysostom uh and Thomas
Aquinas than I am to nistbum or to the
stoics but I'm also not coinciding with
with Aristotle I can see that the stoics
are on point and I do think that you
know it we need to distinguish between
like having an overarching assessment of
anger and then the individual bits of
the analysis and so I think that
Nussbaum has some stuff that's quite
useful I think that all the other
authors that we're reading do as well so
[Music]
um
all right Nora says would you have any
recommendations for work similar to
Lord's assay yeah as a matter of fact I
have a great recommendation which is a
direct response to Nussbaum by a um
another author who's not as well known
but probably deserves to be and that is
uh I may be mispronouncing her name
Maisha Cherry
um
she has a great short little book called
the case for rage and she is advocating
lordian anger
um and saying that it could be useful
for trying to
um
work towards not as a sole uh uh
resource to rely upon but it could be
useful to work for justice within
Society so yeah there's there's other
people out there
um
cancer is very easy for anger to become
brutality and revenge when applied to
theories of Justice
um yeah I mean I would I would qualify
that and say you're right it is very
easy for anger to be translated into
brutality or cruelty to use another term
that Seneca uses and revenge within the
framework of either theories or advocacy
or working for justice and the problem
with that is that you get a lot of
people who are either
um
not particularly nuanced in their
approach and they think that if anger is
okay in some circumstances it's okay
basically across the board or at least
it's okay for their side right
so if you take Aristotle as a prime
example of somebody who thinks that
there is a legitimate role for anger
Aristotle would say you really need to
be suspicious of your own anger and you
have to keep it within check it can't be
running the show and you can't just say
well I'm I'm Justified so I get to to be
as angry as I like that's a vicious
person who or and uh
self lack of self-controlled person who
does that sort of thing and I think that
that you know this All or Nothing thing
that a lot of people have in our society
or various forms of tribalism
um you know do tend to promote that they
give people a pass they say well you've
been wronged so therefore you get to be
as mean as you want no no no that's
that's not the way any of these thinkers
would go and a lot of them would say
like even Aristotle what's a mild
disposition with respect to anger prone
to forgiveness you know so
um
green thumbs do you think Aristotle
would consider the biblical story of
Jesus ousting the merchants from the
temple to be an example of virtuous
anger well so
in order for it to be virtuous you need
to know the person's character it's not
just the act itself right for Aristotle
an action can be in accordance with
virtue without being virtuous so we want
to be you know careful with how we use
that term virtuous
um I mean yeah probably Aristotle would
be cool with that if it was properly
explained to him what the hell was going
on because Aristotle and uh you know the
the landscape the moral landscape having
to do with the temple and stuff like
that it's not like an immediate it's not
like Aristotle would look at that and be
like oh I know exactly what's going on
there it would take a little bit of
explaining for for him right similarly
if you were to bring him into our own
time there's a lot of our own practices
and institutions that would seem rather
weird to him but then he could he could
come to understand it so yeah and one of
the topics that we do discuss in the
class is is you know with this Jesus guy
um
does he get angry or not I mean
the word orge is used in at least one
place in the gospels and there are
actions like the you know cleansing or
scourging of the temple depending on how
you want to think about it that
you know it seems like an angry action
right
um
so yeah we we definitely talk about that
we also talk about something else if
there aren't any any other questions
I'll bring up this what might seem a
little trivial so in The Sermon on the
Mount in you know the gospel of Matthew
Jesus has these um three things that he
says about about the anger and it's in
the context of saying I'm not here to
take away or destroy the law
as a matter of fact I'm here to fulfill
it here's the thing about adultery you
know the law says don't commit adultery
I say if you look at a woman with lust
in your heart you're you're committing
adultery in your heart and then it
shifts to anger it says you know the law
says you shall not murder but here's
what I gotta say
he who
is angry with his brother
it will be liable to the Judgment now I
pause there because in a lot of the
manuscripts he who is angry with his
brother without cause
um
there were different variant texts
floating around of the Gospel of Matthew
and
um
people like John Cassian and John
chrysostom and Augustine they know about
this right and they go different ways
like John Cassian is like
hey I don't care if it says without
cause forget that you know the the real
text is he who becomes angry with his
brother is liable to the Judgment uh
Augustine is like so what is this uh
without cause mean and so it's the same
thing with with John uh uh chrysostom
they're like well you know we're gonna
get angry but we want to not get angry
for trivial reasons or in Stupid Ways or
you know we anger could have some some
useful role but what what is that useful
role and so they you know they devote a
good bit of discussion to that
um not really an issue for Thomas
Aquinas because he's got a whole
different schtick where anger has to do
with the difficult good
um you know
so now here's an interesting question
from BG does Kierkegaard address the
concept of anger and the crowd is
untruth I don't remember
anger being discussed there the anger of
the individual versus the anger of the
crowd
no I don't I don't remember anything
like that doesn't ring a bell
um
I'd have to go back and take a look at
it I mean the other thing to to think
about where this would be kind of
interesting would be the present age as
well right the present age is an age of
reflection not of passion while anger is
a passion
you know the present age comes from this
this Review called the two ages right
um
you know
I would have to go through Kierkegaard
does talk about anger from time to time
but I don't remember him ever really
having
an analysis of it as such but I might
just
you know not be remembering from texts
that I haven't taken a look at for a
long time so
you know there are lots of other people
who we could have talked about in this
class
um but unfortunately you know you only
get um
14 weeks
and then you know a finals week so you
just can't pack that much stuff into
into a semester again this is why it
would be cool to do something like a
series again understanding anger or
um to do some some
online classes about it you know I think
that would be kind of cool
um it is a topic that comes up quite a
bit in my philosophical counseling work
uh because there's a lot of people who
suffer from anger problems and have to
have to deal with that and a lot of the
thorniest anger problems are you know
how do you deal with your anger that is
genuinely legitimate from from you know
uh what Nussbaum calls you know
well-founded anger right
it can be understandable
that you're angry
and yet because you know some real
Injustice some real harm took place and
yet it could be bad for you to get angry
or to act out of the anger or to be
motivated primarily by the anger anger
is a really really complicated emotion
um you know it's really quite
interesting that in um
Aristotle's work
anger is the most complicated of the
passions or emotions you know you look
at the definition of it it's got all
these different moving Parts Thomas
Aquinas agrees about that in in platonic
philosophy you've got this aspect of the
human soul that's called thumos you know
and it's important it plays some some
key roles but it also can really really
get you into trouble you know
um it's it's something that all these
people
have to uh
think about and and what's amazing is
you know like when we teach philosophy
classes we typically don't talk about
this stuff but so many thinkers have
something
cool or interesting or intelligent to
say about anger because it's been such a
big problem throughout uh the ages you
know
all right so uh Caleb says I'm a student
at a university in Boston I've been
fascinated with philosophy and watched
and listened and read content as much as
possible for years well that's good yeah
so
um at a university in Boston oh here we
go so how would you recommend going
about discussing philosophical topics
uh with my peers and professors who
don't know of my Fascination well um
in a place like Boston you can probably
find some philosophy meetups and clubs
and stuff like that probably even in
your University and what's cool about a
place like Boston is you know let's say
you don't go to Boston College but you
go to you know UMass or something like
that there's nothing that says that you
can't like look up clubs at Boston
College or vice versa right so
you might want to look for the people
that are engaging in discussions
and uh you know you should probably see
what the philosophy department and other
similar related departments on your
University campus look like you know
whether they're having events that you
can go to usually there's like talks and
events and things like that that they'll
they're not going to like say oh you
can't come in here you're not a
philosophy major so that that could be
good
um
so philosophy topics with professors
that don't know of your fascination
that's what office hours are for you
know
and you I would do it with a light touch
you go in and you're like hey uh
you know I'm interested in philosophy
are you interested in in this stuff what
can we do you know to talk about this
stuff together office hours this is a
little bit of a side topic students
usually don't take advantage of office
hours and professors are required to
keep them so that's when you go in and
talk with them right that's that's uh
when you can do your one-on-one with
them
um as far as your your fellow students
or peers
um you know there's probably some that
are interested in philosophy but they're
they're not necessarily interested in
exactly the same topics that you are so
you got to have kind of a bit of uh
willingness to stretch you could say as
a matter of fact that reminds me I need
to get in touch with this former student
of mine who's still down at Carthage
College I think graduating this semester
who who wanted me to bring down bring me
down to talk to their philosophy Club
sometime this uh this spring uh we'll
have to figure out a good
day and time and schedule for that
um it's a good reminder so all right any
other well we're already like 40 minutes
in
um quite a lot of stuff uh that we've
we've covered any other questions or
comments that people have about this
class anger philosophy
I don't really have a lot of other
um
material
to talk about
um other than you know this will
probably be something that
I try to bring to Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design I actually did
um
propose a class on this a while back but
not not with exactly the same
orientation
uh and it didn't get into the hopper but
we can see in the future Jason is their
philosophy that covers music yeah I
suppose there's probably like a whole
area called philosophy of Music
um Plato and Aristotle talk about the
different you know musical modes in
um
you know in the uh Republic and in the
politics so there's definitely people
that are discussing music throughout the
ages
um I don't know because I don't
specialize in this sort of thing what
you know
philosophy of Music in the present looks
like I'm sure there's probably lots and
lots of stuff if you just Google it you
know
um and there's plenty of application for
using philosophy in relation to topics
that come up in music so you know for
example one of the things that Scott to
really and I have talked about quite a
bit is you know metaphysical identity
when does a band cease being that band
you know can you have a band that has no
original members in it for example you
know so yeah
all right Kola moose says is there any
differences in how anger is understood
between cultures you've found when
reading different philosophers
um that you found interesting same for
similarities you found interesting
between philosophers from different
backgrounds so yes and no
um first it's very important to to
realize that there are massive
differences within cultures so you don't
you don't have to necessarily start
looking to you know exotic cultures that
we're not a part of or anything like
that even in ancient Greece and Rome and
even in the modern period people are all
over the map when it comes to anger some
people are like zero tolerance some
people are like hey man get as angry as
you want and there's everything in
between
[Music]
um
but yeah there there are there are some
differences that get brought up by
authors for example Nussbaum likes as so
does a lot of other people in a rather
uncritical way they love to bring up
this ethnographical study never in Anger
about these peoples that you know are
are teaching their their kids it's you
know it's a small
um ethnic Community uh that anger is
always bad and stuff like that but those
are such outliers most cultures have
like a fairly wide range of expressions
and actions that have to do with with
anger and it plays a role in much of you
know literature and so this is it's not
the same that it's exactly the same in
every culture but it's pretty
um consistent you know in a lot of a lot
of things
all right so not quite sure what uh
milahan is doing there's a cup of coffee
there
um
maybe that's supposed to be this so all
right any other questions comments
matters people want to bring up
while people are thinking about it I'll
say this this entire weekend is
basically going to be consumed with
um
uh building these classes out and maybe
shooting a few videos and uh
working on some podcast stuff and
you know cleaning up this place a little
bit so uh milahan um what do you think
about Heidegger you got to be a little
bit more specific what do you think
about Heidegger there's like a million
things you could say thinking about
Heidegger what are you particularly
interested in
um I mean I know that Heidegger exists
he's an important philosopher
what what it what in particular are you
looking for
yeah so milahan says I went to Barnes
and Noble shot Bookshop and their
philosophy section was terrible yeah I
mean why would you expect it to be
otherwise it's a commercial bookstore
you know
um you're not gonna find a great
philosophy section there any more that
you would have at any of the other great
chains that have disappeared like Walden
books you go to something like a you
know a University Bookstore or a good
used bookstore or something like like
that
um and then you'll find good philosophy
sections but you know you don't expect
that from Barnes and Noble
uh milhan says do you favor Heidegger's
views on beingness or The Human
Condition
I mean parts of them sure I mean there's
no such thing as beingness
but Heidegger does certainly devote a
lot of discussion to being and uh
Green Thumb do you have any
recommendations for contemporary
writings on philosophy of science I do
not it's not an area that I work in
um I work in quite a few areas but I
don't work in philosophy science and I
even you know I I had to study some of
it for my graduate Level examinations
but it was all the classical stuff it's
not contemporary stuff as a matter of
fact there's so much stuff can you know
that's being written right now in every
single field that asking for
contemporary writings on something
unless somebody's like actually working
in that field you're you're not going to
get too many of them
uh Miroslav is there anything you would
recommend to read before being a
nothingness or jump into it so that
starts being a nothingness yeah I mean I
would read some of sartes uh shorter
pieces like existentialism is a humanism
um I would you know
I mean could it be helpful to read uh
some Heidegger some some uh hush roll
yeah but you don't need too much to make
sense out of what sarda is saying or
Hegel or a big song for that matter
um
I mean it's a tough work in part because
he is using a technical vocabulary but I
kind of think that the ideas are not
like super complicated and one thing
that's really good about SAR is he loves
examples and he's quite good at
unpacking them so that makes the work a
lot easier
all right uh Danny Walters I've recently
come across your channel and studied
philosophy sporadically throughout my
politics degree but want to learn more
where should I start on your channel
there's nowhere you should start you'd
start wherever the hell you want to you
know it's like a smorgasbord you walk in
you take the stuff off the buffet that
looks interesting to you and then you
know if that's not to your liking you
can
you know go elsewhere to another
restaurant or you can go and you know
get another plate and try some other
stuff there's there's no one place that
you should start you know it's it
doesn't work that way
um
illahan I've been reading Friedrich
Nature's this book zarathustra it's very
witty yeah true
um
it's uh you know
I kind of like when we get translations
that aren't full of these and the house
and stuff like that because my students
get confused reading it but
um Patrick says should we only be asking
about specific topics here I got in late
it's not clear to me well I give
priority to stuff that has to do with
the class that you know the
um session is about which has to do with
anger and justice but you notice other
people asking other things as well
um
BG anger within the confines of sport is
somewhat interesting yeah Nussbaum does
have a little bit of discussion of that
in
um her Section you know it's one of the
things she does in her books she she
talks you know General stuff about anger
and forgiveness and then she begins with
these these levels right so you got the
the well let's call it the intimate
personal level and then there's this
middle realm that she calls it and then
there's the realm of the political
social and all that and so Sports would
be in this this middle level for the the
most part
um
milahan I wish Marcus Aurelius had more
books I mean we're lucky we have what he
has because he didn't write it for you
he wrote it for himself it's literally
called to to myself you know so
all right uh Caleb I found your series
on Lev shastoff is one of my favorite
it's crazy to me that he and his ideas
are not as prominent do you have
anything to say on chest stuff
uh yeah I like chest off quite a lot
um it's not surprising at all that his
ideas are not all that prominent he had
one major student and that guy
unfortunately died in the concentration
camps Benjamin fondon and uh chest off
like so many other great thinkers just
isn't that read by that many people
because they're not quite sure what to
do with them I mean Nikolai Mulberry is
worth reading right but who reads him
you know
um Alco Inn of York is worth reading but
not too many people that aren't
medievalists read him uh it's just kind
of a common thing you know
all right
um salivan as I am Russian this might be
interesting to me have you ever found
yourself interested in Russian
philosophical tradition if A1 never took
place as something unified well there
isn't a unified Russian philosophical
tradition any more than there is a
unified American philosophical tradition
or British or you know any other thing
um there's lots of interesting Russian
philosophers and
um writers and you know some quite you
know think about Dostoyevsky who weaves
a lot of philosophy into his work
um I think that one of the things that
kind of stands in the way sometimes is
translation which can be you know a
problem right
and getting things out there but it's
also a very crowded landscape
uh pipeline I really appreciate your
Smorgasbord approach it's anti-posing
welcoming and inviting instead of
scaring people away thank you
yeah it's um
uh
people should read what the hell they
want to read you know I've talked about
this elsewhere if if your professor you
know or some you know pundit out there
is saying You must read these and these
and these and these and not read these
because those would be bad for you
they're probably full of [ __ ] I mean
where you should be skeptical of these
people where where do they get their
ideas from you know
um
it's a free country as we say right
Amelia lahan philosophical's corner I
think anger and wartime is very useful
for survival
um no that's not what military experts
say as a matter of fact
um that'll often get you killed and make
you engage in stupid things and this was
an issue back in ancient times Seneca
talks about this in on anger himself
about you know troops that get riled up
and then make stupid decisions and get
themselves killed and captured and you
know fail in their objectives
uh
meshugan her have you seen the recent
Batman movie no I haven't
um
I I don't really watch superhero movies
uh
you know not because I'm totally against
them but I think that the most recent
crops of them have been kind of garbage
you know and I don't really like the
fandoms around it either you know
um
so I don't I don't typically watch
superhero stuff and you know as a kid
um I I did like quite a few superheroes
and Batman was one of them
um
but now not not quite so much you know
unfortunately
it can be interesting to think about in
terms of anger though right
uh BG I remember referencing the Selma
marches and how expressions of anger
would be heavily frowned upon yeah you
know and that's something that we do
discuss towards the the end of the book
um Martin Luther King and his
organization actually would
um do exercises to try to you know weed
out the Hot Heads because they didn't
want people you know creating more
conflict and and creating a possibility
for greater crackdowns and stuff like
that
so
yeah all right well we got about another
five minutes
um
then I gotta get back to
other work but it's been nice uh
chatting with everybody
I'll do more of these I haven't done
these pop-ups for quite a while but
maybe it'd be a good thing for me to
start doing again I used to do them and
I would give my patreon supporters like
a day or two of lead time before I was
going to do them and
um you know sort of like a perk for them
and then everybody else would find out
that the day of so but it took a little
bit of scheduling to make that happen
and then it just kind of fell by the
wayside I think because I was doing
other streaming stuff like the stoic
Saturdays where I was like doing the um
you know walking through the virtues or
I was doing readings from my book
uh oh here we go so Muhammad says do you
agree with Maisha Cherry that anger is
essential for anti-racist struggle so
that is the key term essential and if
you put it that way no
I don't agree that it's essential but I
do think that it can be harnessed and I
do think that it can be useful
so you know that's a good distinction to
to make and to keep in mind and you know
you also want to think about well anger
in what way do you want you know it's
like we're talking about do you want Hot
Heads who are like getting in the the
face of the cops and like you know going
going wild and then provoking a a
response which then affects everybody
or uh you know do you want people
thinking that anger
authorizes them to do whatever they want
or do they you have to keep it within
certain kinds of
um
constraints
uh Patrick do you have any book
recommendations as an introduction to
meta ethics do you have any videos about
it matter ethics sure I have tons of
them you just got to like look through
they're not going to be labeled meta
ethics because frankly meta ethics is
[ __ ] there is no such thing as meta
ethics any any more than there is meta
language meta language is language meta
ethics is ethics you just put a meta on
to it you know when you look at the
substantive ethics that meta ethics is
supposed to be meta to
every tradition has like is doing meta
ethics you know what does John Stuart
Mill doing in a utility uh in
utilitarianism he is doing substantive
ethics and he's telling you how the
other kinds of Ethics out there really
are either covert forms of
utilitarianism or their failures that's
metaethics and meta-ethical positions
all boil down to ethics you know I don't
know why people are so obsessed with
with uh that distinction
um Muhammad what's the philosophical
difference between anger and rage
there's an a philosophical distinction
there's philosophical distinctions that
people make and that are you know sort
of connected to their particular
philosophy there is no one single
philosophical
uh uh distinction there uh my sugar
anger seems to exhaust people quickly
when used as a tool for communication it
does and it doesn't it depends on the
circumstances a lot of these things you
can't make these vast generalizations
and have them be true Muhammad when his
anger virtuous and productive
depends on whose theory you're looking
at why not read some Aristotle on that
right he he gives you some pretty clear
guidelines for that
um or you could read Thomas Aquinas or
you could read Plato or stuff like that
Stephen Franklin anger can bring your
attention to an issue but reason should
guide your response yeah so that's
that's you know nussbaum's
idea of transition anger you know you
leave the anger itself behind eventually
Aristotle could endorse that
um Seneca would say you could actually
do without the anger you're probably
better off without it in that case
um Patrick brief thoughts on moral
anti-realism I don't have brief thoughts
on moral anti-realism I don't do isms
for the most part isms to me are sort of
shorthand for who knows what you know I
don't begin my thinking generally in
those terms I look at what particular
philosophers have to say about things
and uh I don't I don't start at that
level of generality so
all right
um
got about a minute left any other last
uh minute questions comments stuff like
that
uh my sugar and her favorite favorite
sadlerism I don't know to sadlerism is
so I don't have any favorites of that
Muhammad what are the principles of
lordy and rage why not get the why not
read the actual
um text uh that's it's very short you
know the uses of anger and then you can
read uh Misha Cherry's book you know
um
she's out there she's very public in in
her uh
her work she's done lots and lots of
interviews and written a lot so she's
easy enough to find
all right so we'll wrap up here and uh
I'll say
have a good rest of the weekend to
everybody some of you might be tuning in
from uh you know much further east of
here and it could be night time for you
or maybe some of you are you know uh
further west and it's just early
afternoon or perhaps even the morning
for you so I'll see all of you uh or
some of you at least
sometime down the line and I will talk
to you later maybe I'll do some other
stuff about this class down the line of
something cool happens in class it gets
me thinking I don't know now I actually
got to like get all the work done to get
ready for for this class so I'll see you
later